hello and welcome to this video playing
hmm Allah Eldon maybe and that's some
tempting huh let's do it
do you never know if they actually have
some own great a Sicilian knowledge some
people really gamble I think own idea
3c5 and they don't really know this is a
Sicilian all that well
okay yeah if you need to think here it's
too busy it's a start of the theory and
now Knight f6 or e5 is normal yeah that
is a somewhat uncommon choice yeah is it
bad though probably not
yeah I think C 3 and d 4 it's probably
making the most sense with the night
being somewhat offside playing in the
center is kind of logical no it looks
fine let's see he's taking a long time
listen to castles no I think this is
actually not bad
I have night a 3 C 4 and I mean the
whole black setup is kind of odd
yeah ok this is played of course I
played h3 because Bishop g4 was an
annoying idea but maybe I should have
played d4 immediately
and five of course tries to make sense
I'm sorry out of the night on age six as
some interesting idea serum even e5 is
an idea it's probably not great though
[Music]
maybe this I know what it gets the night
back into the game but with this movie
I'm preventing him from gasoline yeah it
was Bishop f1 and now back but ok at
five is a pretty substantial change to
the position so it makes sense to
reconsider what what I'm doing okay now
how do we get the quickest possible
development I need to get those pieces
out what is this idea ecigs maybe you
six and then Catalan okay II 6 I have F
FOIA that wins you six yeah yeah it does
Whitney six for some strategic
concessions but I don't see many people
playing it six here
sacrificing a pawn place this one but
what's it I ever take your d5 I can also
take the bishop which will be of course
excellent as well but what happens if i
take I don't I don't get to move at all
I mean my position is quite well
coordinated not not they don't have many
unprotected spots or weaknesses so maybe
it was just a mouse Lib no to be three
is better 92 to c4 I want to keep this
or a3 to see I want to keep this option
okay so he wants to play Bishop Age 2
and then and then nothing much
okay another time is not so great but
the position is more or less winning
okay but [ __ ] - this might be five why
is he going
to be eight I guess I didn't really
think about that move at all that's not
good
okay can't you cannot take the night
because of Bishop a war that is
something that I did see attacking the
bishop and annoyed 13 seconds it's not
so nice but I just take the piece next
month I think take take this first and
h2 are still hanging and now it's made
its body in the morning but still what a
joke
[Laughter]
this is the way to lose the game yeah
it's difficult otherwise I have to do a
five question mark move just psyllium
can do whatever Ruby for ya okay I mean
it's early in the morning but this is
really no excuse yeah what black did
here was basically a suicide mission
putting the knight on to age six I don't
know and then Queen to b6 and that's
really a lot yeah I came it is six h3 f5
and I'm happy with my player early until
i blundered mate yeah this d3 dt5 is
just I don't know what it is I just take
it the engine gives me six I'm not
surprised I thought that this is
actually an idea because after f4 and if
he goes back I can grab these six but
this is not actually
that great I saw that hmm
but as I said I don't see many people
sacrificing this really the spawn and an
interesting point is that and that the
engine had it in display as an idea at
least is I can possibly take this is
probably going to be very good
compensation for the exchange with the
night coming here and this is hanging
yeah I mean black exposition is
extremely weakened in all kinds of on
all kinds of squares and the king will
never be safe so this is an idea I'm not
sure what I would have done yeah d5 is
just a blunder Queen b3 okay I'm but it
doesn't really matter this is a
completely winning position here Bishop
g5 for stronger yeah but 95 is also plus
plus a lot yeah they're looking for a
six look h4 not the best but okay just
wins and now just anything yeah looking
for or whatever yeah looking for as
strongest and I'm still I'm just up a
piece this is hanging yeah I don't know
I don't know really just I didn't feel
so fresh to begin with but King edge to
is of course very silly and the only way
to lose the game to blunder a major in
in one almost yeah okay guys that is a
bit of a shocker but it happens thanks a
lot for watching